[Music]
yo wassup isolates welcome to winners on
a Wednesday every single week every week
I pull someone else well this is become
financially free as a direct result of
our training programs and then what
happens is you benefit from that because
you can learn all the lessons struggles
and tricks and tips that Bank them to
become financially free and you can stop
implementing them in your daily this
week we have a guy called Colin comes a
teenager he's 19 years old he's
financially free he's done it very very
quickly as a result of training
Calabar come to the show grab a madman
she soars come down
yeah so I'm 19 I'm studying dr. Brooks
doing economics politics actual business
from a theatrical financial sort of
mindset already and I got I sort of
started up into investments value
knowledge I'm disagreed everyone else
out which is Google stock how to make my
name and body body bar and it just it
doesn't usually work out very well
because the appearance game to know why
and Google's full of absolute knows yeah
yeah people say oh you get the
information online free you can you know
perilous but 99.9% of it all were
written by the broke-ass University
students who just wanna get clicks for
every there more lectures that Marcus
let some lectures to start you know it's
all about talking about and especially
the teaching about business yeah if
you're a lecturer at the University
she's not business houses yeah why else
yeah I said maybe if you enjoy life you
going to a teacher
yeah but you've got the success that
back it up yeah
that's the difference so you stop
googling stuff yeah because I mean
basically in this department why is my
mom passed away last year from a
specific time frame category clear past
ever multiform so that's that's what
we're homers always self charity that
sort of this research is that and who
you rather I'm sorry what month was yes
it's it's sort of like this of because
mom never had like real financial
instability from you today she works
long hours very hard working is any
nurse for a long time and so she was the
waving of inheritance through and I was
like why don't you know I was he any so
sort of start to see it taking away you
know I didn't like that as Indian yeah
well so because obviously I was like I
was saying yeah it's 12 pound there and
the three pound there but it does had up
and it just sort was decreasing very
very rapidly and so I sort of start to
Google these things and eventually came
across you know property investing as a
whole which obviously didn't find a
student here about but then I started
looking like okay I wanna buy a property
so I was looking at Oxford which as you
know is extremely expensive
yep and it was like I think I wasn't
gonna flap about 250 K X by and it would
have used all of my inheritance I didn't
like was a factoring in legals my heroin
of all descent and then suppose I'm
always broken
no chance yeah but income you're not
going through a business you're not
doing this you know they value 19 you're
used to you know in it you forget it
way to 21 and then way other two years
like yeah so no no man
yeah people sleep on columns yeah yeah
they just ditch it was give us no every
time I try to ask aggressive no the
house and one who's walking you say 25th
up is that no 25 seven okay so it was it
was a kind of weird because start moving
to and then still gave up for a while
and it was three months ago in the
summer I was working night shifts in a
petrol station so I was 10 p.m. to 6
a.m. and that's where I read both your
books around
Alistair's book but I actually found you
because of you know cookies on my web
browser that save your browsing history
like it was because that I was at though
on YouTube there 2 o'clock in morning
and just because of like what previously
searched your video pops up I was like
all right leave that world forever
and then what you know Here I am so
video was remember and you know I don't
know the title the video but I remember
it was when you long before you need to
London and you weren't a roof I think
was the roof of your house and it was
where someone like it was a Q&A style it
someone had written in saying I'm 17
only it's property you know what's the
best thing for me to do right now you
sort said we do you can do it you know
there's nothing stopping you the time
you want painting over the head is very
reasonably no I was 19
so I'm 20 November so I was 19 time yeah
I was only saying it seventeen year I
can do
yeah exactly and also as well in your
position you were quite vulnerable
because got a little bit of money by
those the money people 40 grand whatever
it was but you've got people that
they'll be doubly finance planners and
so all this you need to do with it you
know this isolates this which is mostly
a terrible thing to do I mean probably
the worst you can do we should just all
of it yeah yeah that's why you wanna or
just spend it slowly on bills and stuff
but then put it into analyzer what
everybody still gonna shrink yeah
whether because of cost although you
might get very tiny
growth the the inflation will work but
sense yeah I mean I have got like a
really small amount of money in stocks
which make about 5% year so I'm still
growing slightly like inflation but yeah
it's it's not so what was it about me
and Ponzi in general that really
attracted you know it wasn't I think
initially I was just thinking about the
money and I was more thinking like my
mom hasn't left me this money for me to
go
you know wasted we were spending on
bills so initially it was just about
making sure that money was you know it
was used to do what it was intended for
us or set me up for life so it was more
the passive side of things that I sort
of thunder and the more I know today I
mean I'm always buying property like you
know I like interiors and watch many
another listing know that was really no
listing you're like it's like you know
it like it's food it HD all the time
I love that show right and so with
meanings of property yeah Wow I never
sort of thought like I mean it wasn't
very million dollar listing I never
thought I thought you know
lots of money yeah I think what sort of
pushed me into is a well you said about
the seventeen-year-old being able to do
it and then sort of be obviously got the
energy denim energy was bright
I just didn't see anyone else doing it
and so I think that initially attracted
me you know and then it was when I read
because I was like facility to a 2 a.m.
YouTube wormhole and just ended up
watching lousy videos then or oh through
all the sound Alistair's book from that
and has probably two days where just
what two shifts at work I just to work
and was reading like in the other night
crying read those and then I watched
James Armstrong as well as on a
Wednesday yeah you thought usually yeah
an original one I was like why I think
you probably know that maybe I'm a I
think he was a and thought I just saw I
saw it I was like I want that yeah I
want that to be me so I sort of you know
when you see someone on YouTube and you
idealize them
yeah maybe put on a pedestal that like
that unreachable yeah you won't get
three stone over time well I I saw I saw
messaged him fully expecting him not to
reply and then I think when he replies
it sort of gave me the confidence to
today so immediately say to you so
initially I actually messaged him asking
if he does finally deal I just obviously
me all the way across he had money
at the time forehead when realistically
you have this time and so I just needed
messaging like that I mean I had he sort
of asked me what my strategy was how
much I was like that's it all look like
the normal questions you'd ask an
investor what they want and I've
realized how little I knew and then I
sort of saw see and it's the trend that
like everyone wears a Wednesday or mean
everyone a lot of fortunate people had
been through the Academy yeah it was
because of that that sort
boosting about maybe there's so much
quicker so I see within that
conversations like before you have 5
minutes of crash course o clock ticking
it early could you revert Japan yeah I
just says I would run the Academy yeah
like I don't know what it was the baby
did it but I just part of it was just
here applying you know genuinely
beginners he just gave me more
confidence so he said the other I was
silent for a school service at the
academy but I will take your trash was
so not probably we can get you on it
would you all over the phone
James do this yeah it's it's work for us
no it's same as you now but you're
working more messaging you and you just
want to help people
yeah yes and everyone at the phone
buzzes telephone call with someone over
there so majors mean they know what they
want to do right and they just you know
they're saying oh I might like to do the
education versus start an 18 months as I
know is you forget the education do it
now when you'll remember it yeah you
want to
that's exactly yeah so my message David
just said that I'm gonna join the
Academy flower end of story
soon as I yeah we're getting down the
fun and you know the team to come talk
to you
so that was happening I was waiting for
a reply and there was crush what's that
mean there's a lot of scratch was before
you went way over August yeah and I was
desperate I was on the Facebook groups
Norma's stop trying to get this ticket
midnight on Wednesday Eve this is how is
my personal honestly at the midnight on
Wednesday evening I've got the tip it
was a message James on Thursday morning
and I've got a tick is crash-course I'll
be in every weekend like getting signed
up booked hotel look straited here was
that weekend and for the record if sold
out and you begging people yeah you know
can I compete with inspecting it
definitely puts warm yeah I probably
posted on the Facebook group 10 12 times
posting every night at 3:00 hour no
other people just I don't want to wait
all this time
yeah he's working the metro station it
was genuinely making me ill because the
like schism like like terrible sleep
from having terrible eating pattern you
know it just it was just I was not good
so how do you like it's interesting that
you put some of my own education like
you've got an inheritance and
straightaway you say a bank
I don't know some people see as you
follow in your own education and get
across walls but actually I believe that
property is the second best thing to
invest in the best new staff area I
think that definitely comes from online
she was because she never got a pretty
good education right so she always like
persistently wanted us to go into going
getting an education go to his school
and just make sure that we got was she
didn't have
so think that's why that sort of comes
from hands again while the reason like
what James is asking me over strategy
and you know these two competitors I had
no idea what sounds like more if I don't
know what I'm doing yeah how do I put my
faith in someone like what I don't know
yeah yeah understand the concept of it
so I was like what I understand humans
and so I understand first several books
yeah it probably was a long few years
and so I sort of just plowed into it as
I thought you know what if it works I'll
get the money back anyway yeah because I
know the training you mean yeah if the
training works up on yet I'll get the
return on the investment through
investments yeah doing it properly so I
like the crash course the weekends
straight up straight away and then yeah
that the following week it was the
launch pad and a revolution oh yeah so
you did the regulatory like that week in
those seven days I was in London more
than I was actually at my own house
right so crash course Academy in Japan
went to rent training you must dig use
one yeah all at once and then yeah so it
was a big blow by a little bit yeah yeah
it was it was it was intense at all and
it was like it's a step up from the
crash course book is the crash course
yeah it was there to learn but the same
time I thought this if there's a lot of
time waster this is the people man the
vegetables yeah because it's broke
believe me we deliver the crash course
oh yeah like we teach we teach like
crazy
but because of the people in the room
there girl they're all over amazing but
they're not paid to be there no I'm
gonna paint this with you know and
that's what's so cool probably start
charging for these courses yes because
it wouldn't pay for something games like
I just like I've been to this weekend of
you know pathetic crash course just yeah
yes just we call this networking for one
and there's all different types declare
but it's not just like people I can get
money from it's like trays trays people
material suppliers there's all these
different types of people there and it
just and even the information no to
crash courses are the same so the one I
went to in London was very different
when I went to Birmingham and when I
went to you just go on the in the
original one I didn't think about you
nobody healthy yeah well I just money
start with but then we didn't teach it
because they just like different by the
next week on Menace across schools young
Muslims everyone next week only be there
this weekend there's a thousand people
there your ah yeah bro yeah so okay
University you realize you only versus
money well you're the best introduced
gonna speak to yourself
yeah you've invested yourself you go
crazy and it happens you might see a lot
of course it back to that real quick
within the economy yeah last couple
months what you don't
okay so when I read retro evolution yes
which was great did you secure a rental
in one moment sort of gone so we were
given its policy you know why God
created them wrong yeah I don't know why
I was no excitement maybe you get
someone had to find the deal
yeah and how to finally sort of contact
people and then Russell was like okay
you have half an hour to go make some
cool
actually hold on there you go ten
minutes oh so he said this Apple
everyone probably have the room try to
find some signal this is what about
basilic downstairs it was no signal in
the international room and several is
running out for my cause I mean by eight
photos in that ten minutes which is
pretty good very good like really flat
out no and it tasted simple whether you
bring them up and you go this is what I
do and they go yeah okay yeah yeah
exactly on the forum there we go yes and
I can offer this funny I knew that this
oh yeah say he's a lonely hero but that
evening I think that was the second day
and that was the second day look at the
retro Revolution and that evening I was
going out for drinks with with a few
people and that was my food get changed
and like really aware so I got half an
hour to spare so as I you know what I'll
send a few messages in luxury right so
send out ten messages with my ten ten
eleven messages another and by but
before midnight
I had seven replies to those messages I
viewed all seven of those properties the
following week six of them were terrible
poor location or condition were things
away and you wouldn't go yeah I think
never to view the properties so yeah
when 22 properties and took something
using my master my work with me because
he was also interested as I talk to
girls happen if you can't be enjoying it
you must want to lose it when they
haven't yet yeah so I got some good
people around yeah
yeah yeah so that they got mad with his
next match yeah he used to run like that
assisted care business so he'd provide
housing for the disabled people and
things like that so he's having more
property so he knows a lot about like
refurbs and stuff like that and I'm done
so for me I was like well he's probably
going to provide a much better quality
of property than I was you know pure
legal is his experience so if you can't
meet John and he suggested job mentoring
I was like yeah let's do it
so we're going to be this one bit flat
and Japanese man winning and she she's
out of the country a month out of the
year she doesn't want anything but she
it's a lot of hassle person I manage the
properties and policy being in danger
and so we sort of sat down there about
three hours of it and it turned out that
she has not only just one min flat at
this firehouse as well so we walked away
there that day with both parties sort of
security principle imagining and we
looked at it that house was the
wonderful activity great as I say has to
be about the energy moments anyone
better yeah so we then looked at a house
of it housing expired license helps us
which is kind of a rarity as it was
before so good to doing it as a renter
and hazier home
it gives moving up a flat plate like a
single area and we would have made about
five hundred pound each
so we profited about a thousand pound a
month but which is get the partner
perhaps gift but then you will appear in
this essay and there's no problem get
you know average of because the two
rooms the landlady's paying for us
oh yeah so you know gonna get about
average of 85 are like rhythm yeah says
instead of crossing thousand have a
month total net profit it'll probably be
more like 5,000 pounds their profit
warehouse okay
oh yeah that's not good
yeah it was good it's fully occupied and
it's what you will be yeah and usually
over five one nights 425 pounds for a
night yeah I've got rent for a second as
well yes yeah and I'm at is a dream yeah
sometimes they're at their evolution oh
yeah yeah you know how does hypocracy
that you've got a fire right yes yeah
that's a house yeah yeah I didn't know
if it was gonna work but like the start
I sort of that if the deity just got
about this sort of focused on like oh
how do I make take care of them I'm like
well you need to focus on small things
it's not like pieces at first
and so we still just agree to do it and
then figure it out later
yeah they said I just have five lot
maybe six lock boxes the keys so this is
all secure about the cover aside
contracts all sign and are the two
properties so off of those two because
since I spoke to us man opposed to if
they're both occupied our sense pipe say
yeah yeah it will be about three
thousand pound em over to me Wow
then with once the another crash course
so I slowed down a little bit I feel
like those two do sort of I got
overconfident
that was I thought I don't need anything
else so I slowed down a bit in August so
I've got the deer that was signed and
then sort of midway through all this I
slowed down somewhat not doing as much
yeah this is bad so when another crash
course just to give me a level of which
one of these other thing about bank
accounts which had those horses fully
wet what happened see that these two if
I've got a monthly thing also so
everyone more than three comes this
crash course just just a few weeks back
yeah people will enhance the
relationship with your team and Mark
James Armstrong then witness they yes
that's where network said was that was
sort of the main reason I went was a
sort of give us a little kick and some
beads a network nitrogen yeah and this
little bit people sign up to the cab you
know it's like they want to know what
it's like so being there you sort of
share experiences and then you've got
that sort of link with someone else on
the Academy yeah so yeah went to that
and then it was it like a week or so
that this September the if he was gone I
was there and went to that Russell did
doesn't a bit about went to REM and he
just asked as anyone did they all go as
a training in August I went to
revelation yeah deal off the back of it
and so I've got my hand and you know
you've got me mind kid going to break
down the deal and but it was clearly
impressed by it literally how many
people that didn't even 354 there are
three battlezone yeah I'm pretty sure I
spoke to every single person in that
room a whole bow I walked time to stop
about hundred
is that because because you stood up and
muscle called you out here and so ignore
touch we have a UDS a buddy yeah I'm
like yeah that's me
and then won't get through a vegetal
document I had someone walk up to me it
sounded it was do them well I didn't
actually have any tails to sell so know
about degree she had yeah that would
have been a sweet penny yeah but I had a
guy walk up to me and literally after I
had that sort of section just finished
it went for a break it was yeah it was
the practice before lunch and he walked
up to me lovely guys named Vinod and he
said that I've got these two properties
in near reading this is about fighting
this way for Ascot I'm just secured
through an aging on rent to rent their
new bill block of flats oh but yeah I
was like what no stuff and I say before
maybe thinking that he was like ask just
asking for advice for what to do as I
know that I want to adventure oh no so
Wednesday then I was at lunch time
that's the power of Max's oh man
and then the next day Saturday because
it finished on Friday limit you know so
Saturday I went to read them be the
properties secured them that would like
by the 15th because dude fastest us and
then well that's like the billionth I'll
show you video over there and the
building has not even been finished yet
it's dust bait we've got to in phase one
and offer us the penthouse in Phase
three
they take you through some are I'm
really impressed
there is so much business and service
opportunities out there and seeing you
utilize it and
Network Lao and joint venture people is
also and also understand the power
because honestly man I follow people
supposed to call me Wednesday because
they say oh no because he forgot mine is
Wednesday all my family gonna want
something oh man that's such no question
poverty mindset spit actually I've got a
point rather than that my my sister's
are two sisters and they're very
different
I thought with me my oldest sister is
she's just like had a kid
and everyone's pretty happy the healthy
healthy baby and she wants to buy a
house outright knew she wasn't as much
money down as possible I keep that [ __ ]
keep track so she's probably been watch
this and so paid before but at the same
time I can't run so it's not really the
right thing to do terribly was Susan
right okay like and said that's a
pedigree maybe for that but I didn't
yeah the Baha'i international living man
she was she was security and I was I do
understand the fact she's got baby and
she was security but at the same time
I'm like that you could do so much
enough Emily was in the crash course bro
well funny you say that my other sister
she sort of she's in an admin job and
she sort of there's a notice what I've
been doing is I've been president my
story a lot and trying at social media
yeah up they're launching YouTube
channel soon of these backgrounds and
from hopefully this Friday is coming out
so that's exciting but I spoke to my
sister Emily the younger one wasn't too
after the if anything I said that he
need to get off this because she has the
same amount of inheritance as me she's
quite a status over when you need to get
on this you just need to just come down
through a brush which that I was next
one
it's like Emily you aren't need what she
goes to the cross yeah lame and she
signed up and she's coming November so
so that if people I go I don't come with
one but it's I think it's my family the
ones that for me well they can have
stuff from me if they get an education
first
yeah example and then join Manchuria get
the knowledge
well financial freedom alone is actually
boring yeah well I hope you make why
don't you free because of it where I
didn't have this environment was kind of
alone in the light and then suddenly I
was thinking man I want to travel people
tell me this and most of my friends now
affirm people I've had so many friends
asked me to tell them and I have one
front year in the wolf of Wall Street
when he goes you show me a paycheck for
how many thousands of pounds right now
if I don't come back for you yeah I have
a friend say so if you show me a
paycheck for for six thousand pound a
month and I'll get much out right now
anything grew between you three thousand
three and bucks
so we said I want to see six thousand
I've got it but don't come on for you
know so I mean no I wanted to quit this
job but at the same time when I attended
to square now knows it so much me I
nothing to lose man I think might be
year or up see you know what when I was
17 I was afraid yes managing your
policies because in humanity people's
properties for free what happens is the
more money others experience about
managing property and my performance in
general but nobody you positioning
yourself or others my moves yeah I'll do
that paycheck man yeah well young thing
is I'm moving quite unique positions
about other fact I get a lot of student
loan because I'm the only one support
much info application so many new we
zoom I'm saying it to do over there so
the other six bank accounts so yeah
funny someone hoping not as you Det yeah
so I'm hoping is by the time the what
I've got that my student loan runs out
before Christmas
yeah I would have got all the pledges I
probably in sighs I should have by
apartment by the 15th of October a chef
for properties live maybe three it
depends on the and then I've been
offered another one in Eaton actually
was just just downstairs and we're
looking at this group of five of us who
were looking at buying a block of 12
flats in Scarborough which they wanted
in his service combinations I'm in the
block and you're gonna then what went on
for you were the boys well no no no so
it's basically it's a guy called
Christian he found it and he sort of was
a bit because he was always my first
vehicle yeah he was a bit too big for
his first deal wrong so he was like oh
I'm I just said I want to be an investor
and then someone else go digital Academy
members as well someone who I presented
through the Academy Farouk he called me
and he was like I've sort of told him
not to sell it because let's just get
team together let's do it by ourselves
even if it means we're getting less each
we use other people's money and we'll
get an infinite turn anyway so it's
irrelevant just let's just do it as a
team so the group of five us and it's
looking like we can buy all red on
Britain violence pull a lot of the money
out that 130k left in it which is
realistic and nothing
when the even be ours so that unlimited
that right now which hopefully might run
high part of their service combination
the rest of single that's yeah it's not
ready we're not require our exactly yeah
hey the ROI by this describes you kind
of following a lot of people do this
only Academy checks are against you jump
guys take a few entrants that can
financially frame the experience and
then start working on big deals yeah
come on windows Wednesday then run
themselves to all the tracking programs
that it's not jointly room people on big
deals
well that was the thing as well for me
because I'm nineteen uni you have no
income I was like bye first things first
I can't sell the fact that ninety I'm 19
right that's impossible time change sir
imma give me yeah okay also can't change
that I'm not gonna drop out and
everything I can change my income right
now says get cash flow
there's get as many rent events as
possible get as much cash as possible
because then no one who can turn me down
on fire to the affordability you notice
yeah so I was like right if I've got if
I've got the income that's fine because
then I can just get someone to guarantor
it or whatever just seal it so I can
actually did that might sort of the tool
box that I can use experience quite
drastically as soon as I've got that
income yeah and it means that I would
have so much like these flats I have
tiny puppy as it is because of the cat
boiler the rents relatively with me so
for me it was a very much case of of
cash flow and that's what was talking to
will the guy had a phone call with
yesterday about I was like because he
works 40 hours a week
and he wants he wants to sort of
subsidize as income he doesn't quit job
is he enjoys a job which okay as I'm
sample but he was our only duty real
soon I said well realistically if you
work 40 hours a week you're not gonna be
able to provide the level of like
quality of service to your clients as
you realistically should if you want to
do it to say Alistair's you know because
I
just a bunch of other stone you're
saying ugly when he first started out he
was staying in hotels four or five
minutes a week - yeah so I said why
don't you just get a little bit cafe for
that's getting one rent to run and then
use that subsides to read come roll back
your hours and your job and then you can
use that to do all sorts you can use
your spare time and so he's gonna use
gonna be the crash course on Friday
Vicky's learning languages now for
education
yeah and I think if you work out like
I'll be making six thousand had a month
off of the deals that I've got right
I've done the rent read to crash courses
so far and the DfE and was either
lasagna which a lot of us pray by the
way how's the trying to be as well being
so far really good really good yeah
nothing this for me is the
accountability mm-hmm it's someone sort
of especially in my mastermind group
sitar Anton out especially they we've
got a few big things planned plan flat
and then just accountability probably
yeah like my for example I'm looking to
be haven't get an office in the near
future and talked about before I was
thinking about it he was like why don't
get an office I was like well because
I'm I think I've no know why don't come
off it's an office yeah okay I could be
with you right environment as well yeah
it's such a wide set things about I get
so much more work done even even if I go
to a cafe yeah but just being in my room
is not the right place I think you need
to have that area that you can just sort
of step back from going to implement
support and that's the same thing with
you second others within the Academy
doing the environment
people yeah and that's the thing with
the crash course if I feel like this
yeah people are there to learn and bar
there's a lot of time wasters because
you said they don't value what they're
being given so yeah awesome
yeah I know and it's just it's annoying
as well because they you talk to so many
people you spend so much time with them
and then they just drop off the face of
the earth
mm-hmm I hope it was the story about the
guy you tell you you've got that police
option for and then he thought God I
going live free lease option an
experiment no the one with where you
went you went to the house and it was a
[Music]
capitalist are you talking about the
ball young mr. Singh yes yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's like you spend so much time
then poof gone yeah and I think that the
Academy because everyone's paying money
to be there yeah and they're serious and
if you don't take it seriously then just
leave no one's gonna love you you want
people to like you see you next series
well I know that you drop a pound if you
weren't serious know exactly and that's
the best are thing and that I'm pretty
sure I'm gonna get messages from my
family going
you did what you spend how much you go
to war and it's gonna make me laugh in a
way because it's a lot money but um I
don't think those are gonna make home
what I've spent a month things out like
I don't think these speeches to strike
or align each other investment yeah and
I think people consider so well man I
really appreciate you support thanks for
making evangelist what we do what
continues for you welcome any particles
anytime
I think this
this week there's a thousand people or
actually more I'm gonna get you on stage
you can sail away
nice thanks man hey listen I hope you
found inspiring this intercom finding on
Facebook follow man stalking come down
to 40 messages crash course as well get
yourself in the environment successful
people if your five friends if you'll
find closest friends are not financially
free you'll be the same person that will
also not be financially free so come on
down join the family meet the team I'll
leave a link below for the crash course
completely free on the house okay I'll
see you there
[Music]